hoy Hablamos de una de las principales
protagonistas del Super Bowl y no
estamos hablando precisamente de un
jugador no Andrés hablamos de Rihanna el
artista de Barbados que regresa a los
escenarios este domingo para el
espectáculo de medio tiempo A las 6 de
la Universidad de Phoenix acoge el Duelo
entre los Kansas
para determinar al nuevo campeón del
fútbol americano profesional de Estados
Unidos la velada va a estar amenizada
por 13 minutos de Un Show en el que
Rihanna promete rendir homenaje al
Caribe a la población afro y a los
inmigrantes Pero sobre todo es un
homenaje a ella misma por su maternidad
lo dijo en la rueda de prensa previa al
evento
cuando te conviertes en una madre
simplemente hay algo que ocurre sientes
que puedes tomarte el mundo puedes hacer
lo que sea y el Super Bowl es uno de los
escenarios más grandes del mundo
así que sin importarlo miedoso que era
porque no he estado en un escenario en
siete años hay algo emocionante en ello
y es importante para mí hacerlo este año
es importante por lo que simboliza es
importante que mi hijo vea eso